hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will ihr habt ihr jetzt schon ein
paar rezepte von mir für eine
silvesterparty oder für eine andere
party bekommen und ich finde auf einer
guten party davon salat nicht fehlen
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht sein ich
habe ich heute mal ein salat rezept weil
wir es auch so viel lieber süßes hatten
und ich möchte jetzt einen salat machen
dem auch gut vorbereiten kann
das ist nämlich eine schicht salat den
macht ihr einen tag vorm verzehr können
in den kühlschrank stellen und dann das
sieht auch richtig toll aus und es wird
in seinem glas geschichte dann nehme ich
mir hier dieses glas und dann sieht man
hier außen die einzelnen schichten dann
denke ich den schön mit folie ab die wir
in den kühlschrank und dann wird die
party eben ist oder wenn unternehmen
eure gäste kommen können sie einfach von
oben nach unten löffeln so dass sie von
jeder schicht etwas abbekommen und ihr
habt mit anklicken und dazu zeige ich
euch jetzt einmal die zutaten und zwar
braucht ihr hart gekochte eier ich habe
jetzt hier selbst stimmt ich werde aber
nicht alle gebrauchen
es kommt ja auch zu fahren was viele
schlüssel benutzt ihr braucht gouda oder
anderen käse den wir noch rein müsst ihr
braucht etwas porree also so eine laub
stange dann etwas mayonnaise da könnte
auch die light-version nehmen wobei ich
light versionen nicht so gern mag von
produkten
ihr könnt sellerie nehmen aus dem glas
eine ananas habe ich hier schon ganz
frisch geschnitten könnte auch aus der
dose nehmen aber ich finde die ananas
besser weil sie nicht so wie es ist
einen etwas säuerlichen apfel das ist in
bern etwas mais aus der dose und ich
habe jetzt hier noch ein paar eingelegte
mandarinen die als auch aus der dose
könnt ihr theoretisch auch frisch nehmen
müsste aber daneben enthalten und sitzen
jetzt natürlich nur vorgeschlagene
zutaten so wie ich es eben gerne mache
ihr könnt da aber zum beispiel auch noch
etwas punkten schenken
eingeben schmeckt sicherlich auch ganz
gut aber ich finde es da wir so immer
ziemlich viel mit fleisch essen finde
ich mussten salat nicht auch noch
fleisch enthalten
deswegen mache ich salate gern
vegetarisch jetzt zeigt sich einfach wie
das alles vorbereitet wird die sache
müssen jetzt nämlich noch alles schön
klein gewürfelt werden und vor allen
dingen der chor da ist ja auch ziemlich
dreckig dann zeige ich euch jetzt den
sauber machen
der pole hatte immer ziemlich viel sand
zwischen den blättern deswegen schneide
ich denn erst klein und was ihnen dann
ihr könnt aber auch so machen da oben
die wurzeln entfernen
aber so dass er noch das wurzel stück
daran habt und dann wird der einmal
längs halbierten geht es so macht hafte
hat dann später hall bringen und keine
ringe mehr um jetzt gehe ich an den
wasserhahn und trennendes hier blatt für
blatt auf und laster das wasser
durchlaufen und zwar schön aus und bei
porr ist es so dass ich hier noch die
dunkelgrüne und stellen weg schreit
gäste nämlich die ganz bitteren stellen
deswegen achte ich da beim kauf darauf
dass ich nicht so viele dunkelgrüne
stern mit drin hab weil das ja so
zurückgeschnitten wird und falls sich
allgemein ganz gern
ich mag es auch so klein gewürfelt auf
dem butterbrot mit etwas alles finde ich
immer total lecker weil man erstens was
gesundes ist und zwar richtig lecker ich
gehe es jetzt schnell aus spüren also
einfach die blätter hier auftrennen
wasser durch und dann ist der kopf
richtig schön sauber
jetzt habe ich den ball richtig schön
gewaschen etwas trocken geschleudert und
jetzt weder einfach noch kleinen
schritten und zwar schaltet ihr denn
jetzt einfach inhalt bringen da frage
ich hinten an sie dann etwa so drei bis
vier millimeter breite stückchen ich
beginne jetzt einfach hinten weil vorne
die wurzel hier alles zusammenhält und
das eben nicht auseinanderfällt
nach vorne hin schneide ich die halt
bringe etwas dünner weil sie ihre größe
sind natürlich werde jetzt viele sagen
das porträt im salat natürlich sehr
stinkt das ist leider so also da kann
ich euch recht keinen arzneimittel dafür
geben was dagegen hilft hilft ein
kaugummi oder ihr werdet wieder single
es ist einfach leider so aber ich finde
story gibt diesen salat ebenen richtigen
geschmack
mir brennen der augen mit da gibt es
erträgt dass ihr während im schneiden
durch die nase atmen er nicht mehr durch
den rat mit sondern durch den mund
dann steigen diese karte nämlich nicht
in den kanal wo er dann eben die tränen
bis klein geschnitten
jetzt kümmere ich mich nur um die
anderen sachen ich habe hier meine
ananas die ich frisch aufgeschnitten hat
bei mir sieht es doch spiralförmig aus
durch meine andreas schneider und jetzt
werde ich ihn einfach klein würfeln
das geht jetzt ziemlich einfach dann
nehme ich mir den ring und schneider
ihnen kleine stückchen von ihren teils
auch so viel anders wie er das möchte
manche möglich ist er gar nicht immer so
süße früchte im salat hat man zum
beispiel sein können
der macht es absolut nicht wenn das obst
in seinem salat drin hat und ich stehe
der strahl drop also ich mag die
kombination aus süß und zahlt sich und
ich finde sehr lecker aber wenn ihr es
eben auch nicht mögt dann nachlass da
einfach die mandarinen und die anderen
aspekt ihr könnt ihr da auch paprika und
alles mögliche rein schichten oder
champignons und alles was ich eben ein
fertigen was euch schmeckt als nächstes
müsste jetzt den apfel noch klein machen
und da kann ich euch gleich mal nächstes
werkzeug zeigen
ich finds immer toll wenn ich euch
werkzeug zeigen kann was richtig
praktisch ist und zwar ist auch was von
romys ich werde jetzt aber erstmal den
apfel schädel mit einem ganz
herkömmlichen sparschäler übrigens auch
richtig toll ich habe nur noch leute
machen sich halt einfach so wenn man
viele der küche arbeitet und ich hatte
echt schon viele geräte und viel
werkzeug und irgendwann merkt man
einfach west geräts hauptfahrwerk nicht
und ich finde das sollte man dann auch
rein investieren weil man auch viel zeit
in der küche verbringt und das merkt
aber erst der jenige da eben auch in der
küche arbeitet also dass man einfach mit
so einfachen sachen viel zeit sparen
kann und ich bin zeid ich sowieso das
wertvollste von daher passt es deswegen
hier diesen apfel entkernt und das
besondere an dem ich einfach dass der
sich öffnen lässt
das heißt ich muss später hat diese
kerne da nicht raus drücken sondern kann
das öffnen einfach aus schieben
es wird hier angesetzt und dann kann man
das auch durch drücken
hab dann schön
danach war schön den apfel entlockt das
macht die samir auch immer ganz gerne
punkte durch und dann kann ich das wie
gesagt hier einfach rausnehmen und der
achtung jetzt noch fein gewürfelt werden
ich werde jetzt einfach 14 dann nehme
ich hier meinen schneider hier so ein
schönes gitter das heißt ich trinke
schöne feinen stückchen dann lege ich es
hier rein
und alles andere erledigt das gerät für
mich schöne beine apfelstückchen und
alles im handumdrehen mit den hart
gekochten eiern mache ich genau das
gleiche
die werde ich jetzt hier halbieren und
dann bleiben sie auch hier drin
schön fallen gewöhnlich jetzt hat das
eigentlich so gut wie geschafft jetzt
muss die mayonnaise vorbereiten
und zwar habe ich ja ganz normale salat
mayonnaise und weil es gerne etwas
leichter haben möchte kann jetzt zum
beispiel etwas joghurt mit rein geben
weil ich finde meine leser allein immer
so ein bisschen schwer aber wenn man da
bisher joghurt mit reingeht dann wird es
etwas lockerer und ich mach das jetzt so
dass ich dem einen esel ein gefäß gebe
natürlich eine schöne unterstützung und
ich gehe jetzt zur mayonnaise etwas von
diesem mann der ihren saft mieter so
einfach um das so ein bisschen
geschmacklich aufzupeppen
ein bisschen und dann wird es auch etwas
flüssiger und wie gesagt noch ein
bisschen naturjoghurt das ist weder
dieser zehnprozentige tür beschädigung
oder gehen natürlich jeder andere
joghurt
und dann eben deutsch einfach ein
kleines gefäß ist doch eine kleinere
schale weil ich nicht so viel polizei
habe und da wird es jetzt schon rein
gestestet und da habe ich so eine
gewisse reihenfolge die ihr auch so ein
halten könnt was daneben geschmacklich
so richtig passt und zwar nehme ich
jetzt zuerst die den sellerie aus dem
gas und gibt da etwa zwei esslöffel rein
dann kommt da ein bisschen von dem apfel
drauf da mais und jetzt gebt ihr hier
noch ein drittel dann ein drittel von
fauré die ananas gebe ich jetzt komplett
mit dazu so viel wie ich eben möchte und
wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr jetzt noch eine
portion schinken mit rein geben
dann kommen die mandarinen mit dazu
dann kommt mal wieder etwas und
mayonnaise darauf mit der ein drittel
komme dann gebe ich meine restlichen
äpfel mit rein
wer möchte kann er vor ein paar sellerie
stückchen mit reingeben und gerne noch
mal weiß jetzt kommen noch die eier mit
rein dann nochmal etwas mayonnaise
schützt die letzte portion jetzt gebe
ich noch mein restliches drittel porree
mit rein als letztes kommt vom käse
drauf und habt ihr jetzt gesehen ich
habe es immer so beschichtet aber ihr
könnt es auch ganz anders schichten auf
jeden fall ist ganz wichtig dass ihr
zwei drei mal bei lese mit drin haben
und dass eben alles dann mit der manege
bedeckt ist und im käse habe ich jetzt
schon fertig gerieten und geht den hier
einfach komplett um drauf so sieht es
jetzt aus ich finde ihn so richtig schön
dass sie von allen seiten schön aus und
ich werde nicht so mit folie abdecken
und ihn dann in den kühlschrank geben
wenn ihr aber zum beispiel
ein gefäß habt mit deckel spiele ich das
besser das ist nämlich etwas
umweltschonend weil die folie nicht
verschwendet auf jeden fall musste als
24 stunden im kühlschrank durchziehen
dann hat auch der core i schön den
geschmack von der manege und von allem
anderen angenommen und so kann man die
dann schön von oben nach unten durch
löffeln und hat wirklich von jeder
schicht etwas ich hoffe dass euch dieses
rezept natürlich gefällt und dass er den
salat mal nach macht ich würde mich auf
jeden fall freuen auch wenn ihr andere
anregungen hat was man da noch mit rein
packen könnte
natürlich ist das ganze auch saisonal
bedingt also wenn ich jetzt im sommer
bin dann packe ich da natürlich auch
frische sachen mit rein und die samira
ist schon in kuschelstimmung deswegen
beenden wird dieses video das rezept
könnt ihr natürlich auch nachlesen auf
www.ad torten welt.de und ich freue mich
schon aufs nächste mal
und falls sich das video gefallen hat
freue ich mich natürlich über einen
kommentar oder eine bewertung oder wenn
ihr eben dieses medium mit euren
freunden teilen wird freundes auftritt
erstmals ohne dreckiges szene
das schwein